[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zu zdf heute live es
war nur ein kurzer tritt aber der hatte
es in sich
us-präsident trump schickte um 654 heute
morgen deutscher zeit diese nachricht in
die welt er und seine ehefrau melania
seien positiv auf das corona virus
getestet worden
32 tage vor der präsidenten-wahl schlägt
diese neuigkeit natürlich ein wie eine
bombe denn sie könnte den eh schon
aufgeladenen us wahlkampf beeinflussen
vielleicht entscheidend verändern und
vielleicht auch auswirkungen später auf
das wahlergebnis haben
dabei ist noch überhaupt nicht klar ob
das präsidentenpaar überhaupt erkrankt
bisher ist ja nur das virus nachgewiesen
worden
beide sind auf jeden fall in isolation
die nächsten tage vielleicht auch wochen
werden sie im weißen haus verbringen
das alles wirft fragen auf die wir
unserem usa korrespondenten el mati
wissen stellen wollen vielleicht habt
ihr auch fragen stellt sie uns gerne
entweder über die kommentarfunktion oder
per e mail
schauen wir mal zur native sind der
zurzeit in pennsylvania unterwegs ist
immer du hast heute mit vielen leuten
gesprochen welche reaktionen hast du
denn auf diese nachricht dort erlebt ja
wir haben mit einer ganzen reihe von
leuten hier in harrisburg dass die
hauptstadt von pennsylvania gesprochen
die erste reaktion ist natürlich gute
besserung wünschen die meisten aber es
sind natürlich auch einige dabei die dem
ganzen vielleicht nicht trauen die
unterstellen dass das vielleicht gar
nicht so stimmt da sieht man mal was in
den letzten monaten durch jedenfalls
falsche informationen die es ja auch
gegeben hat an vertrauen auch
erschüttert worden ist aber die
überwiegende mehrheit sagt glaube ich
ganz klar sie wünschen ihm gute
besserung
egal welcher politischen überzeugung man
selber an hängt auch mit der kamera hast
du einige reaktionen für uns eingefangen
und ein paar dieser reaktion wollen wir
uns jetzt gemeinsam anschauen
er hat sich die ganze zeit über alle
lustig gemacht hat es die krankheit aus
china genannt und nun hat er wirklich
cupid und realisiert wie ernst das ist
und hört hoffentlich auf sich über
kurbelt und dem ursprung lustig zu
machen
vielleicht ist es eine gute sache und
bringt vielen menschen die realität nahe
es ist in diesem land es ist real wenn
der präsident des hatte es wurden schon
viele menschen positiv getestet ich
denke er wird okay sein
wir hoffen dass ich persönlich bin dank
schamp unterstützer für mich war er die
richtige wahl
ich hoffe er erholt sich und gewinnt im
november ich bezweifle es zwar aber es
wäre schön wenn das ein moment ist wo
jump ein sieht wie ernst das ganze ist
und unser aller verhalten beeinflusst
hier also ein kleines stimmungsbild aus
pennsylvania immer wir werden gleich die
vielen fragen und die vielen aspekte die
jetzt mit dieser nachricht mit dem
positiven testergebnis einhergehen
beleuchten nacheinander
vorher aber wollen wir uns einen kleinen
überblick verschaffen über das was nun
im raum steht und was dieser tag
gebracht hat der im zeichen von drei
kurzen sätzen steht spät in der nacht
witter trump aus dem weißen haus den
paukenschlag die first lady und er
selbst seien positiv auf das corona
virus getestet worden
der präsident ist nun in quarantäne
alle auftritte sind abgesagt zuvor
hatten medien berichtet trance enge
beraterin hob ex sei infiziert sie hatte
sich im engen umfeld des präsidenten und
seines teams aufgehalten
dem konservativen nachrichtensender fox
erzählt wie es aus seiner sicht zu hicks
ansteckung gekommen
die menschen wollen dich umarmen sie
wollen dich küssen weil wir wirklich
einen guten job für sie gemacht haben
seit beginn der korona krise redet trump
die gefahr durch cupid 19 klein seine
wahlkampfauftritte wie am mittwoch in
die luft minnesota bestritt er bisher
ohne maske wie die meisten seiner
anhänger
noch gestern sagte er bei einer
veranstaltung
ich möchte nur sagen das ende der
pandemie ist in sicht und das nächste
jahr wird eines der großartigsten in der
geschichte unseres landes
erst am dienstag hatte sich trump mit
joe biden ein hitziges tv duell
geliefert auch der herausforderer ließ
sich testen er ist negativ trumps
stabschef verkündet der präsident zeige
nur leichte symptome aber solange dieses
virus grassiert erwarte ich völlig dass
es weitere leute im weißen haus mit
einem positiven testergebnis geben wird
der wohl mächtigste mann der welt hat
sich mit corona infiziert damit dürfte
der wahlkampf vier wochen vor der
präsidentschaftswahl eine neue dynamik
bekommen
sprecht mir weiter mit negativen unserem
us korrespondenten der in pennsylvania
unterwegs ist immer wir haben eben schon
einzelne reaktionen von dir gehört wir
haben welche gesehen und im stück auch
wie würden sie denn die stimmung jetzt
im ganzen land beschreiben nach dieser
nachricht wie aufgeregt oder aufgewühlt
sind die leute dort ja ich glaube die
meisten machen sich schon sorgen
einerseits natürlich um einen menschen
wie donald trump also was widerfährt ihm
wird es so schlimm werden wie es bei
boris johnson in großbritannien gewesen
ist wird es eher ein leichter verlauf
sein wie bei der ihre portion awo in
brasilien
aber man macht sich eben auch sorgen was
das heißt für den wahlkampf für die wahl
an sich da sehen wir äußerungen aus dem
ganzen land sowohl von politikern als
auch von bürgern die einfach darüber
nachdenken was bedeutet das jetzt für
die nächsten wochen und monate wichtig
ist vielleicht dass wir jetzt gehört
haben dass der präsident tatsächlich
milde symptome zeigt also zunächst mal
offenbar schon einige symptome hat der
wirtschaftsberater des präsidenten rico
ist vor einiger zeit vor die presse
getreten am weißen haus er hat gesagt
dass der präsident mit diesen milden
symptomen zunächst mal wahrscheinlich
für die nächsten zehn tage ausfallen
wird was den wahlkampf angeht die
amtsgeschäfte ansonsten kann er aber von
zu hause aus also vom weißen haus
weiterführen so larry kulow
mittlerweile ist bekannt dass auch
weitere personen im umfeld von donald
trump positiv getestet worden sind eben
nicht nur opix die beraterin die bei
mehreren reisen ja in den letzten tagen
mit donald trump unterwegs war sondern
auch mike leigh ein senator aus utah der
vergangene woche samstag bei der
vorstellung der nominierten für den
obersten gerichtshof mit im weißen haus
gewesen ist also ist durchaus möglich
dass noch eine reihe von personen aus
dem umfeld von donald trump nun positiv
getestet werden und es war vorhin eine
sehr spannende szenen oder interessant
zu sehen dass larry copello als er zu
den journalisten sprach keine maske auf
hatte die journalisten haben ihn dann
aufgefordert er sollte doch bitte die
maske aufziehen weil er ja zu diesem
engen kreis um donald trump gehört
er hat ein bisschen gesagt na ja das
wollte ja nicht dann könnte man ihnen ja
schlecht verstehen hat sie dann aber
doch aufgezogen und ich glaube das ist
eben auch ein wichtiges signal die frage
hat das weiße haus hat der präsident
durch die regelverletzungen gegen die
masken pflicht teilweise oder die
empfehlungen des center for disease
control hat der präsident da durch sein
eigenes leben aufs spiel gesetzt und das
eben auch anderer in seinem
unmittelbaren umfeld ja darüber wird
gleich noch viel zu reden sein denn er
hat ja 44 kritik und unmut gesorgt weil
er eben diese massen pflicht häufiger
verletzt hat und auch das in großen
menschenmengen das schauen wir uns
gleichen aber weil sie gerade darüber
sprechen wer jetzt gerade getestet wird
und welche ausmaß noch im weißen haus
unter dem umfeld haben könnte der vize
präsident mike pence wurde jetzt negativ
getestet was ja wirklich nur wichtige
sache ist in er müsste übernehmen wenn
donald trump so erkranken würde dass er
die amtsgeschäfte nicht weiterführen
könnte ja das wäre nach dem
amerikanischen gesetz wonach der
verfassung dann musste mike pence unter
übernehmen
nur für eine vorübergehende zeit so wie
es ähnlich auch der fall in
großbritannien bei boris johnson gewesen
ist das ist erstmal eine wichtige und
gute nachricht dass der vizepräsident
und seine frau negativ getestet wurden
auch joe biden und seine frau sind
negativ getestet wurden also offenbar
haben sie sich nicht angesteckt könnte
man jetzt sagen allerdings muss man das
immer noch mit ein stück weit vorsicht
auch anschauen denn das virus zeigt sich
mit
welcher weise auch erst wenige tage oder
einige tage nach der ansteckung so dass
sicherlich jeden tag jetzt die sowohl
vizepräsident pence als auch der
kandidat joe biden getestet werden in
der hoffnung dass bei ihnen das virus
nicht auch noch nachgewiesen wird
damit haben sie gleichzeitig schon die
frage eines users vorhin schon
beantwortet er fragte was ist eigentlich
mit joe biden der war ja jetzt gerade im
tv duell mit donald trump in einem raum
hier kommt noch eine user frage wo wir
gerade diese frage klären wer denn
einspringen würde
unter welchen umständen pelosi an die
hebel kommen würden nancy pelosi also
die mehrheits führerinnen im präsenten
repräsentantenhaus demokratien und
erklärte gegnerin des präsident
vielleicht können sie uns das kurz
erklären wie sie da in diese ganze sache
hinein spielen würde im fall der film ja
also es gibt da zwei szenarien dass eine
szenario wäre wenn tatsächlich sowohl
der präsident als auch der vizepräsident
so schwer erkrankten beziehungsweise
vielleicht gar sterben würden dann wäre
nancy pelosi die nächste in der
reihenfolge die als präsidentin
zumindest vorübergehend wohl vereidigt
werden würde und das andere szenario was
ist wenn die wahl möglicherweise nicht
stattfindet wenn wir nicht wissen bis
zum zeitpunkt des 20 januar wäre ein
neuer präsident wird das ist aber ein
szenario das uns ja auch schon seit
wochen nun monaten umtreibt weil eben
die große frage im raum steht ob diese
wahl möglicherweise am ende kein klares
ergebnis bringt würdiger noch eins
ergänzen wollen das ja tatsächlich in
diesem raum in bei der debatte in
cleveland ohio etwa 60 bis 80 personen
gewesen sind dazu eben auch noch aus dem
begleittross des präsidenten und des
kandidaten joe biden eine ganze reihe
von zuhörern die dagewesen sind es gab
eine ganz klare masken pflicht wer immer
sich in diesem auditorium auf hält der
muss maske tragen die einzige ausnahme
sind der präsident der kandidat joe
biden und der moderator chris wallace
und wir haben dann die bilder natürlich
gesehen also der gesamte die gesamte
begleitung von joe biden hat tatsächlich
maske getragen
das war aber beim gesamten team um
nicht der fall die saßen in diesem
geschlossenen raum und das wird jetzt
natürlich heftig kritisiert weil man
davon ausgehen musste dass falls
irgendjemand positiv innerhalb dieses
teams ist es dass dann möglicherweise
auch zur ansteckung von anderen führen
könnte schauen wir mal ganz praktisch
auf die sache welche auswirkungen wird
jetzt die isolation im weißen haus des
präsidenten haben für den weiteren
wahlkampf ja das bedeutet dass der
präsident zumindest für die nächsten
zehn tage so hat es ja sein berater
signalisiert ausfällt er wird nicht
reisen können er wird nicht bei großen
wahlkampfveranstaltungen auftreten
können er hat jetzt vorhin auch eine
telefonkonferenz abgesagt die eigentlich
für heute geplant war mit älteren
wählern
das ist jetzt zunächst einmal abgesagt
also es hängt wirklich von weiteren
krankheitsverlauf ab wie schneller
vielleicht wieder auf dem damm ist und
in den wahlkampf ziehen kann
der widersacher von präsident ramco
beiden der wird heute nachmittag schon
seine erste veranstaltung wieder haben
in michigan wo er dann vor allerdings
einer kleineren gruppe von menschen
sprechen wird er achtet sehr darauf dass
man abstand hält dass man auch die maske
trägt und er hat auch holen per tweet
dazu aufgefordert dass als lehre aus dem
was wir jetzt aus dem weißen haus
erfahren haben dann tatsächlich zu
ziehen abstand halten maske tragen die
hygiene beachten also der wahlkampf
läuft weiter auch für das wahlkampfteam
von donald trump also er selber kann
zwar nicht teilnehmen aber er wird
berater und unterstützer sicherlich
einsetzen damit der wahlkampf weiter
läuft die große frage ist was passiert
wenn es ernster wird wenn er ernsthaft
krank wird wie gesagt mike pence müsste
ab einem bestimmten zeitpunkt übernehmen
und dann gibt es natürlich auch
regelungen für den fall dass der
präsident so schwer erkrankt dass er
nicht mehr als kandidat zur verfügung
stehen kann
auch dafür werden mittlerweile natürlich
die entsprechenden szenarios
durchgespielt
aber selbst wenn es nicht so weit kommt
wenn es nur leichte symptome gibt diese
momente der fall ist schauen wir mal
weiter drauf was es mit diesem wahlkampf
macht wir haben eben die seite von
donald trump angeschaut schauen wir uns
die andere
seite von seinem herausforderer joe
biden an der demokrat der den wahlkampf
ja schon seit monaten in weiten teilen
zumindest von zu hause fühlt sich dafür
verspotten lassen musste schon vom
präsidenten als als schwächling als
feigling beschimpfen lassen musste
beiden stets korrekt mit maske gekleidet
wird ihm das ganze jetzt eher in die
karten spielen
naja zumindest werden wir haben es ja
vorhin in den aussagen der bürger gehört
wird das ein punkt sein dass sie sagen
seht man es macht doch sinn die maske zu
tragen und damit kann man sich schützen
also es wird vielleicht bei dem einen
oder anderen auch dazu beitragen dass
wenn er gezweifelt hat zumindest in
diesem punkt entschieden der meinung ist
dass joe biden da die bessere strategie
hat als der amtierende präsident ich
glaube aber dass zunächst einmal die
erkrankung die nachricht von der
erkrankung keine gravierenden
auswirkungen auf die stimmenverteilung
haben werden bei dieser wahl
wir sehen dass joe biden ja derzeit fast
zweistellig landesweit in einzelnen
bundesstaaten auch noch höher weil vorne
liegt vor donald trump auch in den
entscheidenden bundesstaaten zum
beispiel hier in pennsylvania liegt er
momentan deutlich vorn das ist einer von
den sogenannten swing states dh am ende
doch eine relativ kleine zahl von
wählern darüber entscheidet ob die wahl
männerstimmen des bundesstaates an den
einen oder anderen anderen gehen werden
also wir rechnen damit dass es keine
großen verschiebungen gibt zumindest
solange der krankheitsverlauf für den
präsidenten ein milder ist
emma hat es eben gesagt seit monaten
wird trump kritisiert für sein
krisenmanagement in der korona situation
er habe zu lange gezögert er habe die
pandemie erstmal runter gespielt und
klein gespielt damit wertvolle zeit
verloren
der hätte nutzen können um gegen die
pandemie vorzugehen außerdem auch das
erleben gehört hat der selten seinen
mund nasen schutz getragen und die
infektionszahlen zu erscheinen
den kritikern recht zu geben wir schauen
mal gemeinsam drauf die usa gehören zu
den ländern die am stärksten betroffen
sind mit 7,3 millionen infektionen
insgesamt mit mehr als 200.000 toten und
hier sehen wir die
verlaufs kurve über die vielen monate im
juni ging es an mit dem massiven anstieg
ein peak im juli mit 80.000
neuinfektionen knapp pro tag und jetzt
aktuell berichtet dass die johns hopkins
universität von 43 1752 neuinfektionen
binnen 24 stunden das ist der aktuelle
stand spielt den kritikern natürlich in
die karten beziehungsweise scheint ihnen
recht zu geben
donald trump dagegen sieht sich als
effektiven krisenmanager manager und hat
auch nicht gezögert das immer wieder zu
betonen den vergangenen monaten
trump und corona er hat eine besondere
beziehung zur pandemie ihrer bewältigung
und zur maske jetzt schon seit knapp
einem dreiviertel jahr
das scheint das theoretisch im april
wenn es etwas wärmer wird es wie durch
ein wunder weggeht ich hoffe es stimmt
es ist wie ein wunder eines tages wird
es verschwinden es könnte schlimmer
werden bevor es besser wird und dann
sehe ich desinfektionsmittel dass das
virus in einer minute aus lockt in einer
minute und es gibt einen weg so etwas zu
machen durch eine injektion ins innere
oder fast wie eine säuberung das klingt
interessant für mich und dann im juli
doch trump zeigt sich mit maske ein bild
mit seltenheitswert
[Musik]
wir werden in diesem jahr einen sicheren
und effektiven impfstoff haben und
zusammen zerstören wir das virus vor
einem monat dann wird bekannt was trump
schon im frühjahr dem journalistin ruth
wort sagte er habe die vom virus
ausgehende gefahr herunterspielen wollen
du darfst nicht die geringste panik
zeigen oder du kriegst größere probleme
als du jemals gehabt hast ja wenn man
diese zitate so aneinander sieht und ich
kann mir vorstellen elmar auch in den
usa wird das jetzt vermehrt rausgeholt
aus den archiven feld dass donald trump
jetzt umso mehr auf die füße
die kritiker seien krisen management ja
ich glaube das ist durchaus möglich
zumindest die die im krieg schon
kritisch gegenüberstanden was das corona
virus und die pandemien ging die werden
sich bestätigt sehen und es kommen eben
einzelne informationen aus den letzten
tagen noch dazu ein beispiel nennt man
hat am donnerstagmorgen gewusst dass
seine beraterin homepage ganz offenbar
positiv getestet wurde
das heißt man wusste dass eine person
die mehrfach in den tagen davor mit dem
präsidenten sehr eng zusammen unterwegs
war bei verschiedenen auftritten unter
anderem auch bei der debatte sie es an
bord von marino an dem hubschrauber
praktisch gleich neben dem präsidenten
sitzend mit geflogen
beim reingehen den hubschrauber konnte
man auch sehen dass die beteiligten
personen alle das geländer genutzt haben
um in den hubschrauber zu blättern zu
dem zeitpunkt war natürlich noch nicht
bekannt dass comics positiv getestet
wurde aber am donnerstagmorgen war es
offenbar im weißen haus einem kleinen
beraterkreis bekannt und trotzdem hat
der präsident dann am donnerstagabend
einen sogenannten fundraiser also eine
sammlung von wahlkampfspenden in seinem
golf club in batmans new jersey
durchgeführt da fiel einigen beteiligten
auf dass der präsident einen etwas
lethargischen eindruck machte also er
hat im grunde genommen obwohl man es im
weißen haus wusste das eine
kontaktperson in den letzten tagen dann
am morgen positiv getestet worden war
diese veranstaltung durchgeführt da sind
spender dabei gewesen die 50.000 dollar
gezahlt haben für ein gemeinsames foto
mit dem presse
denton und an dieser rezeption daneben
auch teilzunehmen und das ist natürlich
ein punkt der wirt zu weiterer kritik
führen wie kann es eigentlich sein dass
die grundsätzlichen protokolle die es
doch geben muss die grundsätzlichen
regeln in dem moment wo ein mensch aus
dem umfeld positiv getestet wurde dann
so eklatant verletzt wurden
hätte man nicht die veranstaltung
absagen müssen das sind dinge die
sicherlich jetzt im wahlkampf auch
genutzt werden ich glaube nicht dass joe
biden das aktiv selber machen wird der
wirt ich sage mal allgemeiner sagen das
zeigt wie wichtig es ist vorsichtig zu
sein aber andere werden dass an seiner
stelle sicherlich tun und das wird den
präsidenten im wahlkampf natürlich auch
schaden zumal er ja nicht nur sich
selbst nicht an die regeln gehalten hat
und maske nicht getragen habe oder das
was sie jetzt eben gesagt haben an
regeln verletzt hat sondern er hat ja
auch aktiv menschen die eine maske
getragen haben als schwächling als
feigling bezeichnet mit natürlich auch
entsprechende wirkung auf die bürger in
den usa ob man maske trägt oder nicht
ist dort mehr oder weniger zum
politischen statement geworden für oder
gegen jump wird sich das jetzt womöglich
ändern
ich glaube nicht weil am ende immer noch
sehr viele überzeugt sind gerade seine
anhänger überzeugt sind dass keine große
gefahr droht sie werden jetzt sicherlich
beobachten was widerfährt dem präsident
menschen dann milder verlauf ist wie wir
es bei jana portion aria gesehen haben
in brasilien
dann werden vielleicht manche sich
bestätigt fühlen und sagen das ist ja
alles halb so schlimm selbst ein mann
wie der präsident der aufgrund seines
alters ja in einen höheren risiko steht
eine ernsthafte erkrankung zu haben also
vorausgesetzt es geht relativ milder aus
dann werden die sich vielleicht
bestätigt fühlen und wir sind ja die
letzten wochen hier durchs land gereist
und wir haben tatsächlich sehr viele ich
sag mal anhänger auch von donald trump
getroffen die von sich aus immer sagen
zu uns ihr müsst keine maske tragen ich
trage auch keine das ist alles halb so
schlimm einer hat uns gesagt das ist
alles eine lüge und wenn man danach
fragt ja und die 200 über 200.000 tote
im land ja wie erklärt man die acht die
sind an anderen dingen gestorben also es
gibt glaube ich glühende anhänger von
donald trump die sich auch durch diese
erkrankung des
präsidenten nicht beeindrucken lassen
könnte man unterm strich sagen wie sich
die zustimmungswerte jetzt verändern im
laufe der nächsten tage und wochen hängt
entscheidend davon ab wie schwer der
präsident erkrankt und ob er überhaupt
erkrankt
ich glaube es spielt eine rolle aber das
viel größere thema ist für die menschen
ja tatsächlich was passiert wenn er
wirklich sehr ernsthaft krank wird oder
wenn er gar sterben sollte auch das wird
hier offen diskutiert ich glaube das
muss man auch weil wir so kurz vor einer
wahl stehen da ist das szenario
natürlich das eine ist das amt selber
das heißt wenn der präsident nicht in
der lage wäre oder möglicherweise auch
versterben würde dann wäre mike pence
automatisch dann präsident er würde dann
übernehmen weil er als vizepräsident
dafür in der entsprechenden rolle ist
und jetzt denken natürlich viele mike
pence wäre dann auch der kandidat für
die wahl die ja nach jetzigem stand auf
jeden fall am dritten november
stattfinden wird
das ist nicht der fall sondern die
regeln innerhalb der republikanischen
partei schreiben sehr klar vor und das
ist bei den demokraten ähnlich dass dann
die die republikaner selber und zwar
alle 168 vertreter der verschiedenen
bundesstaaten und territorien der usa
zusammenkommen müssen und müssen einen
neuen präsidentschaftskandidaten
bestimmen
das könnte dann natürlich auch mike
pence sein aber das muss nicht mike
pence sein
sie könnten noch jemand ganz anderes
bestimmen jetzt kommt das große problem
wenn sie das getan haben rechtzeitig vor
der wahl dann gilt das natürlich aber
die stimmzettel sind ja überall im land
längst gedruckt teilweise wird ja auch
schon gewählt millionen von amerikanern
haben jetzt schon per briefwahl oder
durch abgabe beispielsweise in
öffentlichen bibliotheken haben schon
gewählt und da steht eben donald trump
da drauf und insofern stellt das die
wahl natürlich vor ganz große probleme
was bedeutet es wenn die republikaner
einen anderen kandidaten dann nominieren
müssten für die wahl am dritten november
und das sind so ich sag mal nicht
vorgesehene szenarien dass es schwer ist
sich vorzustellen dass das ohne ein
chaos ohne größere politischen wirren
tatsächlich abgehen
was ist mit einer möglichen
wahlverschiebung ja die ist in theorie
möglich aber ausschließlich und allein
durch den amerikanischen kongress mit
zwei drittel mehrheit weil die
amerikanische verfassung da sehr sehr
eindeutig ist die wahl findet am ersten
dienstag im november statt und das kann
nur der kongress verändern und das eben
nur mit zweidrittelmehrheit
es könnte also diese wahl auf jeden fall
stattfinden möglicherweise mit einem
neuen kandidaten ich sage es nochmal
unter vorbehalt und nur im schlimmsten
fall falls donald trump nicht mehr der
kandidat sein könnte es würde diese wahl
stattfinden und dann hinterher wird
wahrscheinlich einerseits politisch das
heißt durch das was die einzelnen
bundesstaaten jeweils entscheiden welche
wahlmänner für sie dann im wahlmänner
kollegium oder auch wahlfrauen daneben
entscheiden werden andererseits aber
wahrscheinlich auch juristisch weil
beide seiten dann mit dem wahlergebnis
wie immer es dann wäre vor gericht
ziehen könnten
wir bekommen natürlich auch viele
reaktionen von unseren usern hier und
was sich herauskristallisiert ist das
doch eine menge user dahinter ein
wahlkampfmanöver vermuten dass das nur
gefällt ist dass dieser positive test
überhaupt gar nicht stattgefunden hat
zum beispiel schreibt manfred heeb auf
facebook ein geschickter schachzug von
herrn präsident rhomberg an alle
öffentlichen veranstaltungen absagen und
auf der mittelwelle seine propaganda
betreiben oder sahne schreibt auf
youtube was ist wenn trump als nur
gefällt hat um später zu sagen war doch
gar nicht so schlimm ich hatte recht ist
so ein szenario tatsächlich denkbar
also wir hören das natürlich von
verschiedenen seiten besonders natürlich
von anhängern ich sag mal des linken
flügels in der demokratischen partei
ich glaube das muss man mit sehr grosser
vorsicht betrachten natürlich weiß man
dadurch dass so viele lügen aus dem
weißen haus gekommen sind in den letzten
vier jahren 20.000 allein vom
präsidenten und falschbehauptungen dass
das vertrauen erschüttert ist in all das
was an informationen aus dem weißen haus
kommt gerade in bezug auf corona da
haben wir ja nun in den vergangenen
monaten viel erlebt
aber andererseits stellt sich immer die
frage was hätte der präsident wirklich
ernsthaft zu gewinnen wenn das eine
falsche information wäre ich glaube da
reicht nicht zu sagen na ja er könnte
dann auf diese weise die weiteren
debatten vermeiden
und er würde möglicherweise dann eine
art mitleidseffekt erzielen können ich
glaube das reicht nicht aus donald trump
ist vom naturell und auch von seiner ich
sag mal strategie im wahlkampf einer der
unbedingt die menschen braucht er muss
raus er muss seine anhänger die
glühenden anhänger überzeugen das heißt
das risiko für ihn wäre extrem groß wenn
er nur im weißen haus sitzt das hatte er
ja vorher joe biden vorgeworfen der
selbst ja nur in seinem haus in delaware
und würde nicht zu den menschen
rausgehen also ich sag mal unter
vorbehalt ich glaube eher dass das ein
echter positiver test war ein positives
testergebnis jetzt kommt auch das aber
es gibt da natürlich eine ich sag mal
ein unsicherheitsfaktor
weil wir haben immer und immer wieder
auch erlebt dass es die so genannten
fonds positiv gibt das heißt man wird
positiv getestet kurz danach wird man
negativ getestet weil sich
herausgestellt hat dass der test nicht
ganz richtig funktioniert hat auch dass
es nicht ausgeschlossen also wir werden
einfach die nächsten tage abwarten
müssen das ist es eben berichtet von
einigen reaktionen auf der straße wir
haben auch im strom und bild einige
gehört schauen wir mal auf die etwas
offizielle reaktion da hat die
demokratische mehrheitsführer im
repräsentantenhaus pelosi zum beispiel
heute gesagt dass trump immer wieder mit
menschenmengen zusammenkam oder eine
maske zu tragen sei so wirklich eine
dreiste einladung an das virus gewesen
wie äußern sich andere politiker und
kommentatoren
ja da haben sich einige natürlich auch
genauso geäußert wie nancy pelosi
übrigens von beiden politischen seiten
weil auch republikaner das sehr kritisch
gesehen haben was da in den letzten
monaten passiert ist insbesondere auch
einige nicht alle aber einige wenige
republikanische gouverneure die der
meinung sind nicht hilfreich wenn der
präsident angesichts hoch gehen da
zahlen in ihren bundesstaaten nach außen
hin so ein schlechtes beispiel ab gibt
also keine maske trägt social distance
inc
achtet großveranstaltungen dann
durchführen lässt also es gibt auch
kritische stimmen und allerdings alles
das muss man klar sagen von allen seiten
zunächst mal der fokus darauf dem
präsidenten gute besserung zu wünschen
weil auch ich sag mal sowohl die in der
eigenen partei als auch die in anderen
parteien den kommt darauf an dass am
ende bei der wahl am dritten november
entschieden wird wer neuer präsident
werden soll
und vor allen dingen ist auch eine art
abstimmung ist über donald trump über
seine amtszeit über das was er geleistet
oder nicht geleistet hat und das ist
allen auch mit denen wir so in den
letzten wochen geredet hat das
wichtigste eigentlich und deshalb eben
auch deutlich lieber als wenn durch
sagen wir so eine erkrankung oder durch
irgendwelche anderen dinge wie
anzweifeln der wahl oder ähnliches
nachher das land in eine verfassungs
oder gar staatskrise gestürzt würde ganz
kurz noch letzte frage elfer mit bitte
um eine kurze antwort wir haben ein sehr
gespaltenes land gesehen die vergangenen
tage monate inzwischen vielleicht sogar
schon jahre könnte das jetzt irgendwas
ändern in die eine oder andere richtung
also wir haben gleichzeitig auch gesehen
dass fast alle mit denen wir geredet
haben auch wenn sie glühender anhänger
der einen oder anderen seite sind eine
sehnsucht haben nach einheit wieder
zusammenzukommen und die differenzen zu
überwinden
ich weiß nicht ob diese erkrankung jetzt
dafür sorgt dass man eher mal offener
und ehrlicher miteinander redet auch
bereit ist überhaupt mal wieder
miteinander zu reden
ich vermute eher dass die wahl das
entscheidende ist der dritte november
und dass wir wenn danach nicht beide
seiten versöhnung signalisieren und dann
verantwortungsvollen umgang mit dem
wahlergebnis dass wir dann sehr
unruhigen zeiten weiterhin entgegensehen
herzlichen dank nach harrisburg wo der
tag erst halb vorbei ist danke für diese
einschätzung und informationen
us-präsident trump ist positiv auf das
corona virus getestet worden dass wirbel
32 tage vor der präsidenten-wahl
natürlich den wahlkampf komplett
durcheinander
was das heißt für den präsidenten für
den wahlkampf für das land
was für reaktionen geht das haben wir
beleuchtet in den vergangenen minuten
danke dass sie dabei erfahren und wir
wünschen ihnen noch einen angenehmen
habt
[Musik]